الرئيس عندما يتعلق الأمر بترتيب
أكثر المؤتمرات الصحفية جنونًا ، لم يكن هذا المؤتمر
شيئًا يشمّه حسنًا ، فقط اجلس من
فضلك اجلس من فضلك أجلس ، لم
أتصل بك ، عفوا ، أنا لا أرد
عليك ، أنا أتحدث إلى هذا الرجل النبيل
رجاءً اجلس ، كان هناك الكثير من
القوارب في هذا المؤتمر الصحفي ،
إنها وسيلة إعلام معادية ، إنه لأمر محزن للغاية
أنك قاطعته بوقاحة ، لا
يُدعى البعض أنه
انهيار لمقارنته بانهيار الساحرة
في ساحر أوز الأكثر
تصادمية  جاءت اللحظة عندما
تمسك جيم أكوستا من
cNN بالميكروفون وأعقب ذلك شد وجذب صغير مع أحد الموظفين الرابحين ،
وهذا يكفي لأن الأشخاص الآخرين
يكفي أن تعفو عني سيدتي
الآنسة روز لي ، وهذا يكفي حيث يكون
الرئيس أنت ، وهذا يكفي
لإخماد  مايك هذا الرئيس شرع في
الابتعاد عن المنصة ولكن ليس لفترة
طويلة وعندما دافع بيتر ألكساندر من قناة إن بي سي عن
أكوستا ،
كان مراسلًا مجتهدًا ينتهك حقًا ، فأنا
لست من أشد المعجبين بك أيضًا لذا
فهمت  لأكون صريحًا ، شاهدت الكثير من
المؤتمرات الصحفية ، لكنني لا أعتقد أنني
رأيت شيئًا من هذا القبيل
، وفي الفترات الفاصلة بين السجال مع الصحافة
، أعرب الرئيس عن إعجابه
بأوبرا التي أحبها ، ولا أعرف ما إذا كانت
تحبني بعد الآن.  لكن هذا جيد ، لقد
اعتادت على ذلك ، ثم ما شعرت به أنه
عرض زواج عام
أجاب الرئيس على هذا السؤال
بأحد سيدي ، فهل سيكون نائب الرئيس هو
رفيقك في الترشح في عام 2020 ، هل ستكون رفيقي في
الترشح ، هل ستشكرك ، حسنًا؟
حسنًا ، نعم ، الإجابة هي نعم سيدي ،
انتهى المؤتمر الصحفي بدعوة من أجل الانسجام ،
وآمل أن تتحسن النغمة كثيرًا
وأعتقد حقًا أنها تبدأ مع
وسائل الإعلام ، لكن من الأفضل الجلوس أولاً ،
يرجى الجلوس مع
جين موس سي إن إن نيويورك ،
هذا يكفي العفو  لي سيدتي هذا
يكفي هذا الرئيس